>>> ELON MUSK SAYS HE WILL BEGIN
RESTORING PREVIOUSLY BANNED
TWITTER ACCOUNTS.
IT COMES AFTER ELON MUSK
CONDUCTED HIS OWN POLL OF
TWITTER USERS.
NOW HE'S GOING TO DO WHAT HE'S
SAYING NOW.
HE SAYS THE ACCOUNTS WILL ONLY
BE RESTORED IF THEY HAVE NOT
BROKEN THE LAW OR ENGAGED IN
EGREGIOUS SPAM BUT IT'S UNCLEAR
WHAT THE PARAMETERS FOR
DETERMINING THAT WOULD BE.
SO THE CONSEQUENCES HERE COULD
BE GREAT FOR THE EMBATTLED
COMPANY.
A CLINICAL INSTRUCTOR AT HARVARD
LAW SAID WHAT MUSK IS DOING IS
DANGEROUS FOR VARIOUS MAR
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES.
IT'S LIKE OPENING THE GATES OF
HELL.
WE HAVE KATHERINE RAMPELL AND
SCOTT JENNINGS WITH US NOW.
HELLO TO BOTH OF YOU.
SOME PEOPLE MAY SAY THIS SOUNDS
LIKE HYPERBOLE.
BUT TWITTER IS POWERFUL WHEN IT
COMES TO MESSAGING AND
INFLUENCE, AND IT DOES HAVE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, I THINK
REASONABLE PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE
ABOUT WHAT A CONTENT MODERATION
POLICY SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
ONE PERSON'S FAKE NEWS IS
ANOTHER PERSON'S FREE SPEECH.
I'M NOT SURE THAT PRE-MUSK
TWITTER NECESSARILY GOT THE
BALANCE EXACTLY RIGHT.
THE PROBLEM IS, THAT ELON MUSK
NOW IS ENCOURAGING HIS USERS TO
CROSS THE LINE, ESSENTIALLY.
TO BECOME MORE HOSTILE.
AND POTENTIALLY HARASS PEOPLE
MORE.
SO LONG AS IT DOESN'T BREAK THE
LAW.
AND BY ENCOURAGING PEOPLE TO
CROSS THE LINE WHEREVER IT IS,
THIS PLATFORM IS NECESSARILY
GOING TO BECOME A MORE HOSTILE
PLACE TO HANG OUT.
I'M NOT SURE THAT'S GREAT FOR
MARGINALIZED GROUPS AND HIGH
PROFILE INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT
GET HARASSED, ET CETERA.
AND I'M NOT SURE IT'S GREAT FOR
THE BOTTOM LINE OF TWITTER.
>> ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT THE
BRANDS THAT ARE JUST SORT OF
LEAVING TWITTER AT THIS POINT?
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
ABOUT A THIRD OF TWITTER'S TOP
100 ADVERTISERS HAVE NOW LEFT.
OR AT LEAST SUSPENDED THEIR
ADVERTISING OVER THE PAST FEW
WEEKS.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE WOKE
COMPANIES OR WHATEVER, IT'S
BECAUSE THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS ABOUT BRAND SAFETY.
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR LOGO
POSTED NEXT TO A NEO-NAZI TWEET
OR A SERIAL HARASSER OR WOULD BE
TERRORIST.
IT'S DANGEROUS FOR THEM FOR
THEIR BRAND IMAGE.
I THINK WHEN ELON MUSK TALKS TO
HOW HE WANTS TO DECREASE HOW
MUCH THE WEBSITE POLICES
CONTENT, POLICES USERS WHILE
INCREASING ADVERTISING REVENUES,
THOSE OBJECTIVES ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY SOMEWHAT AT ODDS
BECAUSE WHEN YOU, YOU KNOW, OPEN
THE GATES OF HELL OR WHATEVER
THE ANALOGY WAS, YEAH YOU'RE
GOING TO MAYBE DRIVE SOME MORE
L
LOOKIE LOUS BUT YOU'RE GOING TO
DRIVE AWAY ADVERTISERS.
>> THE THING THAT STANDS OUT IS
HOW ELON MUSK IS MAKING THESE
DECISIONS BY POLLS ON TWITTER.
YOU CAN'T TELL WHO'S VOTING ON
THE POLLS.
THAT WAS THE CASE WHEN IT CAME
TO RESTORING BIG ACCOUNTS,
FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP, MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE, AND ALSO THIS
DECISION UNBANNING ALL THE OTHER
ACCOUNTS.
I WONDER WHAT YOU MAKE OF THAT
AND WHAT YOUR TAKE IS ON HOW
THAT'S BEEN HANDLED SO FAR.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
OBVIOUSLY HE HAS BEEN MORE
PROTECTIVE OF GENERAL FREE
SPEECH THAN THE OLD REGIME, AND
THAT'S BEEN HIS PRINCIPLE -- AS
FAR AS I CAN TELL, HIS ARGUMENT
FOR HAVING BOUGHT THIS PLATFORM
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IT'S FASCINATING TO WATCH.
AS KATHERINE SAID THIS IS A FOR
PROFIT COMPANY IT'S LIKE US
BUYING COCA-COLA, OPENING THE
VATS AND POURING STUFF IN, SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
IT WOULD BE A HIGH WIRE ACT
BECAUSE IT'S A FOR-PROFIT
COMPANY.
YOU HAVE TO GET PEOPLE TO BUY
IT.
SO FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE IT'S
FASCINATING.
BUT THE WAY HE'S HANDLED THE
DECISION MAKING IS TRUE TO THE
WAY HE PRESENTED IT WHEN HE
DECIDED HE WANTED TO BUY IT IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
I'M NOT SURE TWITTER GOT THE
BANNINGS RIGHT IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THEY ONCE BANNED THE OLDEST
NEWSPAPER IN THE UNITED STATES
DURING A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T LIKE WHAT
THEY WERE TWEETING OUT.
SO I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY SOME
PEOPLE THAT NEED TO BE BROUGHT
BACK.
PROBABLY SOME PEOPLE THAT
PROBABLY DON'T.
ULTIMATELY, THOUGH, FOR HIM, THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THE BOTTOM LINE,
AND WHETHER ADVERTISERS STICK
WITH THIS OR NOT IS WHAT WILL
DETERMINE WHETHER THIS IS
SUCCESSFUL.
>> SCOTT, I KNOW THAT YOU WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, I'M NOT SURE WHERE
YOU LAND ON THAT NOW.
BUT YOU DIDN'T LIKE HIS BOMBBAS
YOU DIDN'T NECESSARILY LIKE THE
TWEETING.
BRINGING THE PEOPLE BACK, DO YOU
THINK IT SHOULD BE AN OPEN DOOR
POLICY AND DO YOU THINK THE
FORMER PRESIDENT SHOULD START
TWEETING AGAIN?
>> GREAT QUESTION.
WHERE I AM NOW, I THINK WE NEED
A NEW NOMINEE.
WE HAD ENOUGH, TRIED IT TWICE,
DIDN'T GET MORE VOTES THAN THE
DEMOCRATS TWICE.
JUST TO CLEAR THAT UP.
IF HE WANTS TO TWEET, I DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THAT.
I THOUGHT IT WAS WEIRD THEY
BANNED HIM IN THE FIRST PLACE
WHEN THERE ARE OTHER WORLD
FIGURES THAT ARE WORSE THAN
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT HE HAS HIS OWN THING NOW,
HIS OWN SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM.
SO I'M NOT SURE IT'S IN HIS
BEST --
>> IT WOULD UNDERMINE THAT.
>> THE INTEREST TO JOIN ANOTHER
PLATFORM?
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM IF HE'S
ON THERE.
>> CON TRACK CHULLY IT MAY BE
DIFFICULT TO GET ON.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO TALK TO HIS
TEAM ABOUT THIS, IT'S NOT CLEAR
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE.
I THINK HE WANTS TO GET BACK ON.
BUT WE'LL WATCH TO SEE WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT WITH TWITTER, WHAT
STEPS ELON MUSK TAKES.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR JOINING US.
>> HAPPY BELATED THANKSGIVING TO
YOU BOTH, BY THE WAY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.